على كل انت انضمي الينا تنورنا من الرياض
الممثله ريم العلي ريم يسعد مساكي اهلا بك
رمضان كريم نورتنا وشكرا تواجدك معانا في
هالشهر الفضيل في مساء العربيه
يسعد مساكم
واحنا اسعد شرفتينا طيب
لسنوات وعوده نشيطه في 2018 اولا ما اسباب
هذا الغياب
ما كان في غياب انا انا في معلومات مغلوطه
بس مكتوبه عني انا ما بديت
2019-209 انا بديت 2018
فما كان في غياب من الاصل
تبريم اكيد احنا جدا سعداء بوجودك معنا في
مسائل عربيه بس اليوم الاجزاء الثانيه من
الاعمال الناجحه دائما بنقدر نحكي عنها
خطر لانه الجمهور بتوقع دائما مثلا الافضل
هل بتحسه انه وقعتوا بهذا الفخ مثلا ولا
كيف
[موسيقى]
والله انا كنت متخوفه من هذا الموضوع انه
دائما فعلا رزق انه ينجح جزء ثاني من عمل
اوريدي نجح الحمد لله في موسم اول ايوه
كان الموضوع شوي مووترني بس بالعكس نهائيا
يعني الحمد لله مجرد ما العرض من اول حلقه
هو الترند الاول في السعودي الثاني اول كم
يوم والان هو الترند الاول في السعوديه
فبالعكس يعني كنا خايفين بس الحمد لله ما
صار هذا الشيء طيب ريم نقطه اخرى اضافه
اللي قالتها نادين هي انه اعمال تبدا
ناجحه جدا لكن بسبب الالتزام ب 30 حلقه
كما تعودنا في كل رمضان وفي كل عمل درامي
تصبح الاحداث ممله بمرور الوقت بحكم طبيعه
العصر طبعا الان اوان ثقافه ال15 حلقه
برايك
ايه فعليا في ثقافه 15 حلقه لانه الواحد
يعني احداث اكثر وانشدت على فكره صار في
شيء نفسي احنا عندنا من كثر ما نفتح ريلز
في انستقرام تيك توك الاشياء هذه متعودين
دقيقه واحده ونمشي دقيقه واحده ونمشي فصار
الموضوع يؤثر انه احنا ما نقدر نستنى مثلا
30 حلقه نشوف احداث بنمل
اتوقع الموضوع صار ايوه في في مشكله في
الموضوع هذا وصاروا يتجهوا اكثر لل 15
حلقه لثمان حلقات عشر حلقات طيب ريم ريم
اذا بدنا نحكي شوي مثلا عن شخصيه فريده في
منه ولدنا شفنا فيه حماس زايد على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بس صارت في ناس عم
تشبهها بالثعبان فكيف انت قراتي ردود
الافعال
هي فريده انا شخصيا بالثعبان يعني اثرت
علي انا اصلا مع صاحباتي ما عاد احد يثق
فيني يا جماعه عندي مشكله انا الحين اعاني
ايوه فهي فعلا
ومشكلتها طيبه قلبها
بس انا والله مبسوطه ان الناس مره صدقت
قلبي كيف يستوي هذا الامر
هو في افاره مع ابراهيم حجاج علي انه في
احد المشاهد كنت قاعد اقول له انا انا
بريئه انا مش ناويه يعني اخرب حياتك وانت
مشكلتك طيبه قلبك بس انت حيه يعني طيبه
قلبي مشكلتي
طيب ريم بالضبط طيب
ما رايك بذلك اولا
قله ما ينجح في تجربتين ممكن اوكي بس يقدر
ينجح حتى لو في قله يقدر ينجح في تجربتين
انا اشوف ان الممثل لازم يجرب يعني الممثل
ممثل فلازم يجرب نفسه في كل مكان اوكي
يمكن هو لما اعتقد لما ينجح في مكان اكثر
من مكان يكون هو من داخله عنده طاقه وحماس
لمكان اكثر من مكان يعني للتلفزيون اكثر
من السينما او العكس بس اذا هو يعني حاب
الاثنين يقدر يبدا في الاثنين
طب ريم اذا بدنا نحكي شوي اكثر عن تجربه
حياه امراه اخر اعمالك السينمائيه
[موسيقى]
حياه امراه عمل صورته تقريبا
مر عليه الان ثلاث سنوات على تصويره وهو
اخذ وقت على من عرض كانت تجربه رائعه
بالنسبه لي كانت تجربتي الاولى مع سمير
عارف حبيت الناس اللي كنت معاهم وكانت
بالنسبه الي كمان تجربه اولى في السينما
يعني اول اول مره اسوي فيلم سينما كانت
حياه امراه مبسوطه فيها صراحه مبسوطه
بردود الناس عليه وكتجربه اولى بالنسبه لي
سعيده بهذا الشيء انه جربنا واحنا مبسوطه
بوجودك معانا اليوم يا ريم شكرا جزيلا لك
من الرياض الفنانه ريم العلي شكرا ريم
يسعد مساك يا ريم